So, VWAP versus profile, you know, which
one is better? Is there times when one
shines over the other?
Uh you know, can you use them together?
How do you contextualize all that stuff?
That's what I'm going to talk about
today. So, between rolling VWAPs,
time-based VWAPs, anchored VWAPs, TPO,
volume profile, composites, so many
different things to use. How do you pick
one over the other? How do you
contextualize all of that? How do you
use them together? How do you trade, you
know, when they agree, when they
disagree? All of that stuff. All that
stuff matters, right?
So, firstly,
uh when I trade VWAPs, my main focus is
time-based VWAPs, right? I like to use
weekly through yearly. So,
this is my main chart. I mark my
profiles up all my levels, all of that
kind of stuff. I personally don't put a
VWAP on my chart, given I use so many
different levels.
Uh
it would be completely unlegible at that
point. If I had all of these levels on
here, right? And there's probably even
some further down.
It's completely unlegible, so I don't do
that. What I do use is
our indicator, which has labels, which
if you like to use that, it's available
within the Discord.
Anyways,
I don't put VWAPs on my chart. I have
labels for each and every level I use.
That way, I can see if they coincide
with my other levels. So, for example,
you know, I would say, "Oh, previous
quarter VWAP is confluent with uh this
two-day composite value area." That kind
of thing. I can see that on my chart,
and I don't have to go and put the VWAP
indicator on this chart and and check
that between all these levels, cuz it's
it's a huge pain in the ass to deal
with, right?
So, first thing, that's how I like to
look at VWAPs on my main chart.
Secondly,
when I'm actually analyzing VWAPs, I use
this chart here. So, this is four panes.
This is yearly value, this is quarterly,
this is monthly, and this is weekly.
These are the four I personally like to
put most emphasis on. So,
I will quickly preface this. I'm going
to put a profile on this chart.
Uh let's just go like this.
Okay.
This is a 4-week composite. So, four
weekly profiles merge into one. But
anyways,
a profile has a point of control, which
is the mean. It has a value area high
and a value area low. So, this is one
standard deviation either side of the
mean. That's how you get your value
area. The same thing can be said about
VWAP. This is stuff I've covered in
other videos and in extensively within
the Discord, but I just want to preface
this before I go forward.
So, same thing for VWAP, right? So, we
have this is a yearly chart, so this is
yearly VWAP. Yearly value area high,
yearly value area low. This is your
value area, exactly the same thing,
okay?
This is how I like to read all of my
VWAPs, right? So, you have both
developing period. So, if we were to
look at this chart, this is the monthly,
okay? Once a month ends, right? And it
starts a new monthly period, what
happens to the to the prior period?
Well, it's it becomes a static value
area, right? So, if we look at June's
value, which is here,
you can see we open, here's VWAP
throughout the month, here's June's
value area high, here's June's value
area low. Once that month ends, okay?
You now have a static value area, so you
have
previous month value area high, previous
month VWAP, previous month value area
low, right? And then we have the
developing month. So, this is July's
developing month VWAP, developing month
value area high, developing month value
area low, okay?
So,
I just wanted to preface that quickly.
With that being said, using all of
these, it's not I'm trading one versus
the other, I'm only using developing
period, I'm only using previous period,
I'm only using profiles, I'm only using
VWAP. That's not really what it is. It's
it's putting everything together. It's,
you know, where is likely support, where
is likely resistance, where is there
overlap? So, for example, developing
month value area high and develop
previous month VWAP are both coinciding
with this 29.9 kind of region. So, I
know if we trade into this, it's
resistance, right? You can apply AMT
kind of laws to previous period,
developing period, all that kind of
stuff. I'm not going to dig into all of
that in this video.
That's, you know, that's more extensive
stuff. I'm not going to dig into that
and I've prefaced or touched on a little
bit of that in prior videos. Um but
there's developing period, there's
previous period, there's profiles,
right? How how do you go about you know,
doing all of that?
This is how I like to read all of these.
So, I look at what the yearly is telling
me, what the quarterly is telling me,
both developing and and and previous
periods, what the monthly and what the
weekly is telling me, right? Developing
Sorry. Sorry. Yeah, developing VWAPs are
going to Shorter term ones are going to
develop much quicker, right? So, they're
going to move with price as it trades.
And your previous periods are static
value areas to work with. So, between
all of these levels, right? We have
you know, like I said, there's four
different durations of VWAPs here.
You've got previous period levels,
you've got, you know, developing period
levels. You have so many different
levels to use, right? You know,
if if you're below these levels, right?
This will be resistance until proven
otherwise.
Um this will be support until proven
otherwise. You can see that's where NQ
is bouncing right here off of this prior
period value area low, right? Until that
level's lost and it gets flipped, it
becomes resistance the same way value
works with a profile, right? So, don't
overcomplicate it. Of course, you can
apply AMT things and whatnot to these
and I absolutely do. But the point is,
between all of this stuff, it's just
seeing where things overlap and where
they don't, okay?
Now, secondly, we're going to talk about
profiles and market conditions, right?
So, you have two different conditions in
a market. You've got a balanced
condition, right? This is when the
market is building value. And then you
have an imbalanced condition. That's
when the market is breaking away from
value, right? This is when you have a
trend. This is when you have more of a
range bound consolidation kind of
environment. So, when you have a
consolidation or or, you know, the
market is building value, it's range
bound, right? It's balanced. This is
where you can put a profile on it,
right? So, if value is being normally
distributed and you have a normally
distributed profile, you can go ahead
and use profiles, okay? So, if we were
to look at this
Uh let's go like this. We'll use volume
profile, it doesn't matter. Like
profiles, they all work the same in that
sense. We're just going to use a fixed
range volume profile. So, we have 9 days
of overlapping value here, which I've
already marked off, but essentially it's
this area here, okay?
So, if we're building value here and the
market is continuing to be rotational
within value and it builds here, right?
This will continue to happen until the
market breaks out from value, right? And
then it starts to trend. So, this
condition where we just ping-pong
between value area high and value area
low, given that this is resistance,
while we're inside of value this is
support, it's going to continue to do
this until something changes. So,
between profiles and VWAP,
this, you know, value area low and value
area high of the composite or of the
profile are going to be your primary
trade locations if the market is
balanced, right? So, if that's the case,
if we were to go ahead and look at
these, you can see we're building value
here. We're ping-ponging. Same thing
here until we accept it within side,
accept it back inside rather. Same thing
here, support, support, okay? Same
thing, building value. We can go ahead
and just look, support, resistance,
support, right? So, if that's the case
and we're just building value, support,
support, resistance,
resistance, right? These are your
primary trade locations. So, if the
market is rotational within value, value
area high and value area low are your
main trade locations, right? So, if I
was to put this back on the screen,
this is a 4-week composite. So, this is
4 weeks, four weekly profiles merged
into one, okay?
So, with that being said, you can see I
have it labeled off here. This is
support till proven otherwise. This is
resistance till proven otherwise. So,
you can see the market continued to do
this for 4 weeks until we broke away.
Now, we are imbalanced, right? And we're
trading through value, trading through
older areas of value. So, when the
market is doing this, your primary trade
locations are here. So, what I'm saying
by that is if you have VWAP levels like
these ones,
if they coincide with the middle of
value, given we're going to continue to
do this, they're much less important,
okay? So, if we're ping-ponging in a
rotation within value, your trade
locations are at the edges, view up
levels in the middle are less important,
okay?
Um
secondly, I talked about market
condition. We have balanced markets, we
have imbalanced markets or trending
markets. So, for example, NQ, we're
massively imbalanced. There's a couple
times when we found smaller balances, so
here, here, kind of here, here, small
one here. But, overall, I mean, this is
still largely imbalanced and and
something like this, there's no real
balance being found here. So, profiles
are
much less usable if they aren't balanced
or it's not evenly distributed. If it's
a trend day and there's no real balance,
there's not much you can do in regards
to, you know, trading AMT and that kind
of thing with a profile. It doesn't
really work very well, which is stuff
I've gone over in multiple videos,
multiple different times.
So, I'm not going to go over that today.
Anyways, when the market is imbalanced,
a developing VWAP, which develops
quickly with price, so for example,
monthly value or weekly value, becomes
much more of a trade location
because the market is trending, it's not
balanced. So, if we were to look at this
dump here
uh around the beginning of April
on NQ and we go to VWAP chart, let's
look at weekly value, right?
Weekly between these four will develop
the quickest, right? Monthly being the
second quickest, quarterly then yearly,
right? These develop much slower.
If we were to look at this chart, for
example,
and let's go back to that low
back in April,
we have, like I said, like I mentioned
before, we have the developing week, so
we'd have, for example, this week opens,
there's the weekly VWAP, weekly value
high, weekly value area low.
The week ends and then this is that
week's that prior period week value,
right? So,
VWAP, value high, value low. Then the
new week starts and this process will
continue to repeat over and over and
over. And this happens with every
period, but weekly obviously develops
quicker. But my point is,
like I just showed you before in this
chart, we will be a massively imbalanced
here. So, she like this,
you can see that there's no balance
being found here basically at all. So,
given we are bullish, we're rejecting,
like I said, when we have when we have
VWAP here, which is stuff I've talked
about many times,
we have weekly value area high, weekly
VWAP, weekly value area low. If we're
above value area high, it will be
support, right? If we are below it, so
for example, here, this previous period,
it's resistance. So, value area high is
support when we're above, it's
resistance when we're below. Same thing
could be said for value area low, but
flipped obviously.
So, as we continue to trend, value area
high is support, support, support,
support. Okay?
And then the week closes. And then now
we have that static previous week value
area. Support, support, support. Okay,
then we go bullish against the
developing week, support. Same thing.
And then the previous period, exactly
like what I just showed here, happens
here. Support, support, support. And we
start to trend again. Support.
And then this week, exactly the same
thing. Support, support. Support. And
then you can see we start to balance
here more. Now that we're in this kind
of market, then you can start to lean on
a profile more, right? So, then you can
go ahead and plot something like this on
there.
Right?
So, that's your short answer for that.
When do I pick one over the other? If we
are trending, a developing VWAP is going
to be more of a trade location. If we
are rotational within value,
profiles are more of your trade
location.
Right? There's some people that may use
one or may use the other or only use one
or only use the other. I think you're
leaving a lot on the table, right? I use
as many and um you know, I use I use all
of these. I use I use all of them
together. I use anchored, I use time
base, I use rolling, I use all of this
stuff together. And have a way of
contextualizing all of stuff. And that's
a huge part of the the system in which
we trade in Orochi. So,
uh trending, VWAP, rotational profile.
How do you know? How do you use them
together? What You know, what happens
when you're going to you're going to sit
here and tell me that, you know, if
we're balanced, you can only use a
profile, you can't use VWAPs. No,
absolutely not the case.
Go back to my first point.
I think my second point. If we are
rotational, VWAPs in the middle of value
aren't very important, right? So, here,
they're much less important because
we're going to continue to do this,
you know, until something changes,
right? But, if they coincide with the
edges of value,
then they become important. Then this is
more significant resistance. This is
more significant support, right? So, if
we were to look at
the current high of the week on NQ,
okay? So, we have I'm just going to go
off of the profile I used before.
We have a four-week composite. So, we
like I said, we are rotational, we broke
away from value, we are now trending, we
bottomed at previous quarter VWAP and
this two-day composite value area low.
We were able to trade back up. We
retested the four-week value area low,
right? It's support within value, it's
resistance when we're outside of value,
and it coincides with yearly value area
high, right? So, very significant in the
form of resistance, right? And that is
what happened here. So, if we zoom in on
this chart,
that's what happened here, right? So, we
were bullish against yearly value high,
bullish at support. We trade in value,
we retest yearly value area high, it
holds as resistance, and now we've
traded lower, right?
And what do you have here? That
coincides with
the four-week value area low. So,
when VWAP levels are on the edge of
value, if we're in kind of a rotational
or balanced market, then that level
holds more weight.
But, if you were to look at, for
example, previous month value area low,
weekly value area high. Given where
these levels are within price, of course
weekly has developed a little bit since
then because it's the developing weeks
way it will move as price moves.
Um previous month's value area low,
that's not going to move obviously,
right? Because it's a static period.
We rejected this level. It didn't really
care about previous month's value area
low because
we're within value of this older profile
after rejecting
the four-week profile which I just
showed you, right? So, previous month's
value area low being here.
Right? It didn't really care too much,
right? It kind of traded up into it,
kind of didn't, and then we ended up
trading lower, but my point is it didn't
give any clean interactions because it
didn't really care.
Right? So,
using all of this stuff together, right?
It's it's it's a lot. Of course, you
need to way to contextualize all of it
and build a system and build a framework
of what how to read all of this stuff,
but in regards to market condition and
picking one over the other, you don't
need to overthink it. It's not I'm only
trading
you know, previous periods or composites
or developing view up. You're simply
trying to see, you know, the bigger
picture and see where things agree,
where they disagree, where they overlap,
where they don't overlap.
Um you're trying to build up a bigger
picture, right? And like I said, if
we're if we're rotational, profile is
usually more important. If we're
trending or we're imbalanced, VWAP is
going to be more of a trade location for
you.
Um in regards to using them together,
you know, where do they overlap? Do they
overlap? Is there VWAP levels on the
edges of value? If so,
that level is going to be more
significant resistance, it's going to be
more significant support. And that's
you know, the way I like to go about
doing it, guys. So, like I said, if
you'd like to learn how to contextualize
all of this stuff and learn extensively
how we do all of this stuff and kind of
the full framework, you could do so
within the Discord, guys. Cheers.